[Music]
let's go to aaron in
st louis missouri what's up aaron
hey uh not much how are you doing today
good brother how are you
i'm doing okay doing all right uh-oh
what's going on man yeah it should be
doing better um
i'm trying to figure out how to
move forward and
like trust my
very young teenage daughter again after
some really poor
choices on her part
whatever
well
she
she has done some vaping and then she uh
we woke up in the middle of the night
and realized she had snuck out of the
house oh no where'd she go
uh
well you know
she had a boy come pick her and some
friends up
uh they went to ihop and then they ended
up at that boy's house and there's a
large age i mean she's 13 and he's 17.
whoa
yeah
no bueno on that one
no
uh and she has a she had a secret burner
phone
some big trust violations what was on
the phone
um snapchat
all the stuff she didn't want us knowing
about we have bark on her real phone
um the app bark so that you can you know
be safe
but when you when you say snapchat she
sent sending photos of herself out and
about
uh not really photos just
texting with
you know lots of people people she
doesn't even know okay
but we couldn't find any evidence of
photos okay is it is it sexualized
texting or is it just
people
yeah okay all right
okay
real
so how can i help man i'm sorry
well we're we're trying to figure out
how to move forward like
like i want her to have a good life and
fun and
be safe and i just i need to know how i
can learn to trust her again
and what
what we can do
man
so
let me address the the first thing you
said first
i snuck out a lot as a kid
no not from my house because i my dad
was a swat hostage negotiator and a
homicide detective there was no sneaking
out of that home it was a fortress right
i remember one time i went to the
bathroom like i had socks on or
something and i went to the bathroom i
came out and my dad's just standing
there in the hallway and i was like whoa
you know i mean so there was but
buddy's houses i mean we ran the streets
and we weren't bad we were always
wrapping people's houses toilet paper
causing just we're just being idiots um
and so here's what i want to tell you
experimenting trying things out it
it's easy to go i just want my daughter
to have a good life
and so i want you to know like man i got
a good life i don't i i make good
choices now right so i want you to think
all is lost because you have a 13 year
old that's trying to experience the
world
the the loss of trust though is
devastating so walk me backwards how
long has she been pressing on things
the way you're talking this sounds like
a total shock to you is this a true
total shock or have you seen some stuff
coming
and it just kept building and building
like what's your daughter trying to say
to you guys
um
so
i i think it's more of a more of a shock
we did have an incident maybe a year ago
where she met someone online
and that's what
prompted us to install bark on her phone
and since then i thought things were
kind of on the right path
and then
middle of the night she's not in her
room and we're calling the police and
panicked and
what's her response been in all this
so
like
every every single thing that's come out
we've had to dig it out she's toned up
she's to nothing
and she'll always say this is the last
thing i promise i promise i've done
nothing else wrong and then
like
you know
the her group of friends
that were in on this with her like all
the moms are
like detective level smart they're going
through every single
piece of the their lives to figure this
out and so every time
you know we figure something out and
then a couple days later another big
thing comes out and then another big
thing comes out and
so
it feels like it's worse and worse and
it just doesn't it doesn't end
are you still waiting for another shoe
to drop
yes
what do you think is out there
i
don't know
i hold nothing yes i
don't know because there's
there just seems to be more out there
okay
um this is a hard question that i ask
every parent in this situation
where is she picking up some of this
stuff
and when i say some of this stuff i'm
talking about the idea of keeping
secrets the idea of somebody else needs
to
help me feel valued and seen
i need
that burning in my chest i need that
sensation that i'm walking in danger
um where has she learned that
i
think
i mean it's not all her friends but
you know her closest friend is probably
two years older than her almost
maybe a year and a half older than her
and i you know she's just she's kind of
in a different phase maybe at this age
so i think some of it's that and
maybe
i don't know some of the shows she
watches on netflix or whatever
i'm just not sure how's your
relationship with her how's your wife's
relationship with her how's your
marriage
um our
i would say our marriage is really good
and
i try to have a close relationship with
her
but it's really hard right now because
she everything that we used to do that
was fun is now stupid and don't want to
do that and
i try hard to do things with her and
like the only
the only two things that
she will really do with me anymore is uh
she likes to make banana bread so we
make banana bread together and we go
grocery shopping together
um but it's super hard we used to play
card games and board games and
like do all types of things and now it's
that's not what she wants to do she
wants to talk on the phone to her
friends or sure
stuff like that and that's part of
growing up sure so
how's your relationship with your wife
with her mom
um i think it's pretty
i think it's okay
so
like
maybe some head butting there well yeah
some of that's natural but
there's some there's a disconnect here
okay there's a disconnect
if it's
it's good it's okay
there is a conversation about
like there's an openness i can talk to
you about things
there's something that she's picked up
in the environment that says we don't
talk about this in this house
this isn't a safe place to discuss these
things
whatever these things happen to be
i need to go get that sort of
interaction from other people
now like experimenting with vaping is
like that doesn't make me lose one
second of sleep that's being a kid
and is it safe no is it smart no is it
dumb yes is it the end of no i mean like
the kids are going to try stuff out
that's why parents are there for
boundaries
um
but there's something about there's a
wedge in the relationship and i don't
want to blame you and your wife that's
not what i'm doing but i want you to be
honest with your the ecosystem in your
house
it sounds like the way you describe it
again it there's i know it's nervous
calling the show and i'm trying to pick
up on little cues from your voice here
and some of it's just me shooting in the
dark but it sounds like you're hurt
that she doesn't want to hang out with
you anymore or doesn't want to do the
old things y'all used to do like that
gets in your heart a little bit
and what i would challenge you to do is
not give permission for a 13 year old to
hurt you
because she's 13. she's a kid she's a
child she's experimenting right now some
things you told me she likes to do with
you
sounds like she's practicing being an
adult
which is which if i think of it in those
ways that's awesome so i'm gonna start
thinking
i'm gonna more i'm gonna grieve the fact
that you don't play cards with me or do
i wanna play video games whatever i used
to do and now i'm gonna think of ways
what are things we can practice doing as
adults together like what are some of
those kind of right and there's just
that natural distance that a 13 year old
a 14 year old or 16 year old and 18 year
old is just gonna feel from their
parents and that hurts
but if a kid feels like they are
responsible
for the emotional well-being of their
parents
for the emotional stability of a house
they'll crumble under that weight
and so what i would love to see man i'd
love to see you and your wife get really
clear on what boundaries are gonna be
i'll tell you in my house this is gonna
sound draconian and i'm gonna get mean
internet letters about it and i don't
care
in my house if this same thing happens
i am
there is no there will be no phones zero
none
there will not be an internet connection
there won't be social media that stuff's
gone
gone
the access to 17 year olds and 18 year
olds and 28 year olds and 30 year olds
is too great
and your daughter's shown
that holding this tool
that she's not capable of you wouldn't
hand her a chainsaw and just say you
just be careful with this thing honey
you wouldn't do that the phones are gone
and i'm gonna set up some put some ways
after some appropriate punishment yadda
yadda whatever
i'm gonna set up some ways that she can
be in connection with the friends just
going to be on our terms
i'm going to be there with you we're all
going to the concert but i'm driving and
i'm sitting there with y'all
or you are choosing to not do anything
with your friends
and she's going to make it all about my
gosh you're ruining everything
she has to understand and she doesn't
yet because she's still not coming clean
she's still not telling the truth
she still doesn't feel safe to speak out
loud for some reason whatever reason
um
she has to understand the weight of that
consequence and
talking a lot to 13 year olds doesn't
usually work because they're 13.
they have to live it and experience it
and it's hard and it's painful on
everybody and it'd be easier if you just
give her a phone and send her back to
school
um so my house it would be off i would
be spend the next two weeks four weeks
six weeks
you will spend time with us
you'll be out of your room you're gonna
be doing your homework in the in the
family room we're all going to be here
together and i'm going to have to alter
my life my wife's going to have to alter
her life the other kids are going to
alter their lives because we're going to
get in this thing together
and at the same time
if you disconnect her from her community
her friends her 13 year old friends at
school
to a 13 year old brain that will feel
like she's drowning
that would be a a trauma that would be a
terror right and so it's a weird balance
you're gonna have to find here
one thing i might recommend man is
she may not want to talk to you
she may feel scared for whatever reason
i would recommend
getting a
journal that you'll share together that
you write in and then it stays on her
bed she writes in it and puts it back on
your bed and if it's not there in the
next morning or the next evening then
she is choosing some sort of consequence
that you all agree on
um have you
sat down with her or your wife sat down
with her and talked about some dumb
things y'all did when you were kids some
things y'all wish y'all could take back
yes okay how does that land with her
i she kind of i mean i thought it landed
well actually
um
like
you know i told her
i did some of the things she did right
and i told her about it um
with some of the consequences or how
that worked out for us
um
i thought that landed better than some
of the
other conversations we've had
there's something about humanizing a
parent
not just as a power dynamic and as a
rule thought maker and a rule follower
like oh you were 13 too that doesn't
always work but there's something that
is connective about that right there's
there's some connectivity
i i wish i had a nicer way to say this
okay aaron
there's gonna have to be a moment where
you don't take this personally
this violation of trust wasn't an attack
on aaron
this
feels like that right now and your
feelings are running hot
but i want you to step away from she's
doing this to us
and look at it as she is practicing to
be an adult she's trying to make adult
decisions she's leaning into things she
was given access by you and your wife
to the whole wide world and the whole
wide world said well welcome 13 year old
we'd love to have you and everybody went
i
i would be highly concerned about photos
floating around out there
and if there's even a remote hint of
that
you gotta hop on that one quick man and
if people got to go to jail they got to
go to jail if there's people who are
not minors i mean
you you know i'm going there and i know
that's unbelievable to think about your
13 year old but that's where we're at
i want to see you open up some sort of
communication usually writing works if
talking won't
and some back and forth communication
that begins to slowly thaw that space
that frozen ice between the two of you
between you and her and your wife and i
want you and your wife to take an honest
look at the household ecosystem have we
created a space that we have all the
answers this is just the way this right
is there a dialogue in this house have
we made it unsafe for people to talk and
it may be that you sit down with your
daughter and say
i think i've made it
unsafe for you to speak to me to talk to
me to tell me the truth
have i done that
what does it feel like when you when i
ask you if you've done something and you
don't tell it like tell me what you're
feeling
why why you feel unsafe to tell me the
truth even when you've done something
dumb
go that route with it instead of i can't
believe you lied we'll get to the
dishonesty we all know that's wrong
but i want you to connect with your your
daughter the best you can at a human
level
and let her know that you're on her team
you're on her side this isn't you versus
her
there is going to be some really hard
consequences some uncomfortable
consequences but that you're with her
and for her not against her i know
that's hard man i know it's hard
thanks for the call brother
it's not personal she's 13. it's not
personal